[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna have to take you apart again
hey dev anything interesting
make yourself useful
so uh that was fun right
[Music]
that's your cue mate
sleep tight you know what this reminds
me of
my time in the himalayas later
[Music]
you think they can't kill you anytime
they want
hey [ __ ]
[Music]
how do we always get into this
massachusetts behind me we are
witnessing clear signs of
cult activity as the locals engage
[Applause]
hey
i really hope the video was worth it
everybody
fall back people need to know what
happened
with get me on the roof now
thank you layla you're the best oh jacob
don't even mention it
[Music]
[Music]
i've been watching
oh [ __ ] dev's gonna love this one
don't miss i
don't
look a new one
kill me you can't break the blood traps
yeah i think there's vampire in this
really what does it taste like be
specific
like blood and death and strawberry
sun's coming up let's keep moving let's
keep moving
sure thing edgar allen bro that's a good
one
do you think things will ever go back to
normal
would you want to go back to normal not
if i still have to pay my student loans
[Music]
play it day one with xbox game pass
you